[Musique]
salut romain ça va pourquoi tu as des
plumes sur la tête j'ai fait un test adn
j'ai du sang amérindiens ah je croyais
que tu es corse
tu as fait le truc sur internet la non
une petite boutique et briancourt on
écoute quoi les chants sacrés à passe
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr nas hulk pas mes
ancêtres
[Musique]
vous avez sûrement vu beaucoup de vidéos
passé dans lesquels mes consoeurs et mes
confrères recherchent leurs ancêtres
grâce à une analyse adn voulait
peut-être même fait vous même en tout
cas vous en avez eu envie monte pas mais
bon vous avez peut-être hésité aussi
parce que c'est vrai que ça paraît un
peu gros et la première question qu'on
se pose c'est est ce que c'est vraiment
fiable pour répondre à cette question je
me suis moi-même procurer non pas un
mais deux de ses tests de marques
différentes pour comparer les résultats
le premier c'est celui que vous avez vu
un petit peu partout c'est le test de
myheritage une société basée en israël
et il m'a coûté 75 euros parce que moi
je les payais le second c'est celui de
twenty fruits et demie basée aux états
unis et il m'a coûté 108 euros frais
d'expédition compris dans les deux cas
c'est hyper simple on va sur leur site
on passe la commande et quelques jours
plus tard on reçoit le kit de
prélèvement alors techniquement comment
ça se passe avec twenty fruits et demi
on envoie un échantillon de salive donc
il faut cracher dans un tube du côté de
myheritage on a choisi la méthode
écouvillon c'est à dire qu'on se passe
des cotons tiges à l'intérieur de chaque
joue pour récupérer des cellules
épithéliales c'est à dire des cellules
du tissu qui tapissent l'intérieur de
votre bouche et ensuite on coupe le bout
et on le met dans un tube avec du
liquide comme dans les expériences
[Musique]
dans les deux cas on a l'air un peu con
on va pas se mentir
mais bon c'est pour la science alors un
petit conseil si vous faites le test
mangez pas juste avant vous risqueriez
de vous retrouver avec des résultats un
peu chelou
ensuite après m'être assuré d'avoir bien
fermé l'étude quand même l'histoire de
d'éviter de ce même mon adn à travers le
monde
j'ai envoyé tout ça par la poste et j'ai
attendu pour être précis j'ai attendu
quatre semaines pour avoir les résultats
de myheritage et huit semaines pour
avoir ce de twenty free a mis bon et
donc ses résultats globalement ils sont
assez cohérent avec ce que je connais de
mon histoire familiale mais est-ce
qu'ils sont cohérents entre eux dans les
deux cas on est un petit peu au dessus
de 19% pour ce qui concerne l'espagne
donc ça va italien 1% d'un côté 2% et
demi de l'autre on va dire que ça va
aussi
bon après ça se gâte un peu dans un cas
on me dit que je suis à 44,5 pour cent
français néerlandais ou allemand il
raconte ça sous l'appellation ouest et
nord européen mais j'ai vérifié ses
pizzas ces trois pays là et dans l'autre
on passe à 23,3 pour cent quand même une
sacrée différence pour les îles
britanniques pareil d'un côté 9% de
l'autre côté plus de 17% et pour les
pays des balkans c'est pire 1% 17% alors
admettons qui regroupe pas exactement
les mêmes régions sous la même
appellation
ça fait vraiment un sacré écart mais bon
pour aller un peu plus loin on va
comparer mes résultats avec ceux de mon
frère qui a aussi fait le test
a priori la sas tiens on a exactement
les mêmes pourcentages mais c'est
logique vu qu'on n'est pas jumeaux baba
exactement le même adn
bon on résume mes résultats et ceux non
frères sont très proches et pour mes
résultats
dans les deux cas ça reste dans les
mêmes régions du monde et ça colle à peu
près avec ce que je connais de mon
histoire familiale
il ya juste cette petite fantaisie mais
bon pourquoi pas mais c'est pas comme
s'il avait inventé des origines
complètement incroyable
mais d'un autre côté il ya quand même
des gros écarts de pourcentage entre les
deux techniques alors est-ce que c'est
du bullshit
j'en ai discuté avec un spécialiste de
l'adn et de la dynamique du génome et la
réponse est non c'est pas du mytho en
fait ce genre de test ça existe depuis
très longtemps avant c'était très cher
donc c'était plutôt réservé à la
recherche en génétique des populations
par exemple ce qui permet notamment de
comprendre les migrations des peuples à
travers les âges
mais avec les progrès technologiques les
machines et les procédures sont devenus
beaucoup plus abordable au point d'être
accessible pour le grand public d'autant
que ce genre de méthode sa demande à un
séquençage complet de l'adn est comme ça
a un côté fascinant connaître ses
ancêtres l'adn tout ça il ya des boîtes
privées qui ont flairé le bon filon en
fait comment ça fonctionne
notre adn il contient toutes nos
informations génétiques
notre génome et cet adn il se réplique
sans arrêt en gros une molécule adn en
donne deux parcours identique enfin
parfaitement identiques pas toujours
justement il ya parfois des petites
différences qui apparaît cependant la
réplication ces veinards ça donne pas de
maladie mais ça varie un petit peu et
les chercheurs ont constaté qu avec le
temps ces mutations bénigne elle
s'installe dans une population et ça
devient une sorte de spécificités
géographiques
on appelle ça des apps le groupe c'est
un peu les différentes branches de
l'arbre généalogique de l'humanité si
vous voulez et les tests dont on parle
là il détermine les branches sur
lesquelles vous avez des ancêtres en
fonction de la tronche qu'à votre adn
mais attention avoir un résultat qui
indique 19% ibère à dire espagnols un
comme moi ça veut pas dire que 19 % de
mes ancêtres sont espagnols ça veut dire
que dans la séquence de mon adn qui a
été étudié le programme informatique à
déterminer qui avait 19 % qui
correspondait à cette région
géographique j'en ai hérité de 19% ça
veut pas dire que 19% les ancêtres
étaient espagnols
et puis surtout faut pas se fier
aveuglément aux pourcentages parce qu'on
sait que sur ce type de test il ya une
marge d'erreur qui est quand même pas
négligeable
par exemple il ya des marqueurs qui sont
communs à plusieurs types de population
était aussi au fil du temps le
développement des moyens de transport et
des mentalités un peu aussi ça a permis
un brassage des populations qui incite à
relativiser
un petit peu ses résultats tant qu'on
parle de tests grand public donc en gros
si vous avez envie de claquer quelques
dizaines d'euros là dedans et surtout si
vous avez envie de savoir dans quelle
région du monde vous avez des ancêtres
vous pouvez y aller mais dites vous que
ça vous donnera une indication par vrai
rejet la logique puis surtout penser à
un truc vos données personnelles
quand vous faites le test on vous
demande si vous êtes ok pour qu'elles
soient conservés histoire d'enrichir la
base de données et de rendre les tests
plus fiables mais aussi l'histoire de
pouvoir vous proposer des
correspondances avec d'autres
utilisateurs genre vous trouvez une tata
milliardaire en floride par ex et en mai
avoir son génome stockés comme ça dans
un coin même si les sociétés promettent
qu'elles partagent pas les informations
ni avec les employeurs ni avec les
assurances
c'est quand même un peu flippant
d'autant que les mêmes voix propose
aussi de déterminer si vous avez des
prédispositions à certaines maladies
c'est le genre de truc qu'on n'a pas
forcément envie de voir circuler du coup
c'est intéressant de savoir que google a
investi presque 4 millions de dollars en
2007 et plus de deux millions et demi de
dollars en 2009 dans twenty fruits et
demi et que l'une des fondatrices de
twenty fruits amie anne wojcicki elle
était à l'époque marié avec sergei green
cofondateur de google et que sa soeur
susan wojcicki c'est actuellement la
directrice générale de youtube voyons ce
n'est pas exactement quels sont les
liens entre les deux sociétés mais ça
reste dans la famille google et ça nous
rappelle que se faire voler des infos
personnelles
ça arrive même aux plus grands donc ces
tests dans l'absolu c'est du sérieux
même s'il ya une marge d'erreur sur les
résultats annoncés mais surtout si vous
en faites un tank ya pas de loi pour
encadrer ces nouvelles pratiques
réfléchissez bien avant de cocher la
petite case qui permet de garder vos
données personnelles
mais bon toute façon
pour bien tout avant de cocher bien sûr
voilà à détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout
[Musique]